avant de prendre les airs il faut garder
les pieds sur terre alors petit rappel
des règles de la compétition et des
consignes de sécurité
la deuxième chose c'est que les
tournesols va et son très haut
donc évitez les champs de tournesols 26
planeur et une quarantaine de
participants cette année les passionnés
de vol à voile viennent de plusieurs
régions de france et également de
l'étranger
je suis de nationalité belge est sûr que
la région est absolument fabuleuse en
termes d'histoire de france les châteaux
de pierres blanches qu'on peut survoler
je viens de rion des landes
je trouvais que l'idée de survoler les
châteaux de la loire dans une ambiance
conviviale
c'était un joli challenge le but de
cette compétition internationale
survolez photographier un maximum de
château sur 160 édifice retenu par le
club aéronautique plus les châteaux sont
loin plus il rapporte 2 points
vous devez prendre toutes ces photos de
château mais pour l'atterrissage il peut
y avoir des problèmes car on n'a pas de
moteur et les cultures sont trop de voir
ce bourg dans les champs le soleil est
bien au rendez-vous mais attention il
faut anticiper un vent qui souffle à
plus de 40 km heure
mais du haut de ses 40 ans de vol pas de
quoi décourager dit tiens on va se
mettre en péril dans une colonne d'air
chaud avec deux planeurs pour accéder à
leur remontée
c'est la deuxième fois qu'il vient du
département de la somme pour participer
aux coûts c'est la première fois qu'on a
autant de participants et le fait qu'on
ait introduit il ya deux ans une
nouvelle classe qui est à la classe bois
et toile les planeurs de collection avec
ça fait encore venir plus de monde
le vainqueur de la coupe c'est celui qui
prendra les meilleurs photos des
châteaux du centre val de loire
voyager en slalomant entre les nuages et
prendre un peu de hauteur
c'est le programme de cette 14e édition
de la coupe d s'enchaînent